un giorno di tanti anni fa passeggiando
per le strade di bologna mi sono
imbattuta in una frase scritta su un
muro non c'è lotta senza balotta allora
per voi che siete qui non c'è bisogno di
traduzione ma per tutti gli altri in
italiano potremmo dire non c'è lotta
senza divertimento non c'è lotta senza
un gruppo di amici con cui ci si diverte
ed è proprio da questa frase che voglio
cominciare oggi a parlarvi di
cittadinanza mobile di cittadinanza
globale perché nella mia esperienza
tutto è cominciato proprio da molto
divertimento e da tanti amici
correva infatti l'anno 2000 e come tanti
della mia generazione mi apprestavo a
partire per uno scambio erasmus allora
non lo sapevo ancora ma sarei partita
una seconda una terza una quarta volta e
avrai finito per stabilirmi all'estero
allora non lo sapevo ancora e quindi
molto emozionata organizzato delle feste
a casa dei miei genitori chiamando tutti
i miei amici per gli ultimi saluti e qui
vedete due cartelloni delle prime due
feste mc imperi se io parto parti di cui
vado particolarmente fiero e zeppe di
disegnini e parole di incoraggiamento
dei miei amici ora già la terza volta mi
sarei sentita francamente un po ridicola
a mettere un cartellone perché
l'esperienza del viaggio stava
diventando qualcosa di ordinario
quello che invece mi sembrava
straordinario è che di anno in anno
erano sempre di più dei firmatari di
questi cartelloni a partire e magari a
partire e cambiare 2 35
paesi e città di residenza all'estero
allora non lo sapevamo ancora ma quello
che succedeva nel salotto di casa dei
miei genitori era perfettamente in
tendenza con il resto d'italia
infatti secondo l'istat sono 316 mila i
cittadini italiani sotto i 40 anni che
sono immigrati tra il 2000 e il 2010 e
allora non sapevamo ancora ma se c'è un
mistero insondabile è proprio sapere
quanti italiani sono all'estero
infatti se i dati dell'istat e vi
sembravano già abbastanza elevati
sappiate che il centro altreitalie li ha
confrontati con le rilevazioni ufficiali
di alcuni paesi a forte immigrazione
italiana ricavandone delle cifre che
sono 35 più di 10 volte superiori per
esempio qui vedete il regno unito dove a
fronte di 32 mila e 800 italiani che
hanno richiesto il tesserino sanitario
inglese secondo l'istat sono partite
7.400 persone è il proprio divertente
l'australia dove più di 18 mila persone
hanno chiesto un visto di lavoro di
breve periodo e per l'italia sono
partiti in meno di 1.400
tornando alle feste perché non voglio
allontanarmi troppo
quello che è successo e che una volta
messa in cantina i cartelloni ci è
venuta la curiosità dopo qualche anno di
vedere effettivamente dove eravamo
quindi abbiamo fatto una mappa dove
qualcuno tutti potevano mettere le
proprie bandierine quando il risultato è
stato questo
ci siamo resi conto che si stava
materializzando sotto i nostri occhi
appunto in pochi metri quadrati età un
gruppo di amici così tanto numeroso un
network globale capace di avere punti in
tutto il mondo e adesso ce li abbiamo
punti in tutto il mondo perché abbiamo
aggiunto anche l'africa e l'australia
cosa è successo che quindi quando ci
siamo trovati di fronte a quell'immagine
ci siamo detti che volevamo farne
qualcosa ed è stato se non sbaglio
durante un viaggio mio e della mia amica
agnese che vive a monaco per andare a
trovare mio fratello che viveva a boston
e le nostre amiche chiara e valentina
che vivevano a washington e new york che
nell'estate del 2008 ci siamo detti che
quindi quell'anno non avremmo fatto solo
la festa ma avremmo fatto una giornata
di partecipazione che con una tecnica
che si chiama open space technology
molto bella che vi consiglia e si può
dire che quindi il 27 dicembre del 2008
il nostro gruppo di amici abbia subito
una modificazione genetica e si sia
trasformato in expo rete di bolognesi
nel mondo
le domande che ci volevamo porre erano
tremila quel giorno ne abbiamo scelta
una che resti tornassi a bologna su cosa
vorrei lavorare cosa vorrei trovare e la
fine di una giornata in cui
parteciparono un centinaio di persone
alcune domande erano rimaste senza
risposta
la prima è ma torneremo la seconda era
ma quando i nostri genitori avranno
bisogno di noi saranno più anziani come
faremo
altre però erano diventate delle grandi
certezze per esempio la prima era che
avevamo un grande desiderio di
trasformarci in nodi di informazione
cioè di creare un dialogo bidirezionale
tra l'italia e il resto del mondo
partendo proprio da noi dalle nostre
esperienze come dire che se la prima
emigrazione
rimandava a casale famosi rimesse cioè
soldi noi che siamo un altro tipo di
immigrazione
forse possiamo concentrare accesso delle
rimesse 2.0 cioè il nostro capitale
culturale quello che tra l'altro il
nostro paese ha contribuito a formare
un'altra cosa che ci accomunava tutti
era trent che la retorica sui cervelli
in fuga ci faceva venire l'orticaria
non so se avete notato ma funziona
sempre che chi parte o è un cervellone
un eroe che insegue il suo sogno è per
forza successo quindi
oppure è un individualista spietato che
abbandona suo paese che avrebbe tanto
bisogno e che tra l'altro ha speso tanti
soldi per farlo studiare mentre chi
resta tipicamente è uno che scenda a
compromessi o un martire o appunto
qualcuno che ti sa ha rinunciato ai
propri sogni ora niente di tutto questo
corrispondeva alle esperienze di vita
che avevamo noi eravamo amici qualcuno
era partito qualcuno no
le ragioni erano mille ma soprattutto le
domande che ci ponevamo sull'italia e
sul mondo erano le stesse
erano le stesse e da lì abbiamo capito
anche che un altro problema della
retorica dei cervelli in fuga e che era
alimentata da persone che questa
esperienza non l'hanno mai vissuta e ci
siamo resi conto che quindi quello che
mancava era forse una voce collettiva da
protagonisti su questo tema
abbiamo scoperto perché fino a qui erano
cose territoriali di potrei raccontare
per ore delle attività che ex boffa dal
2008 ad oggi e ma potete trovarle sul
sito ci siamo resi conto che
non è tanto facile capire quali sono i
diritti ei doveri di un cittadino
italiano quando emigra all'estero
sappiamo vagamente delle cose su un
registro a cui bisogna iscriversi
abbiamo il terrore della dichiarazione
dei redditi e siamo molto preoccupati
per l'assistenza sanitaria e quindi mi
permetto di segnalarvi questa guida che
è sul sito del ministero degli interni
perché per molti sarà una scoperta ci
sono tutte le informazioni che dovete
avere e vi segnalo anche che da pochi
giorni c'è anche un nam sulla colonnina
sinistra del sito del ministero degli
esteri
una serie di domande e risposte quindi
un formato diverso ma molto interessante
il problema appunto non era che ci
volevamo noi fermare a conoscere i
nostri diritti doveri perché avevamo
capito che quello che è interessante
anche fare cittadinanza attiva
e così abbiamo scoperto una cosa che
nessuno ci aveva mai detto cioè che gli
italiani all'estero possono contare su
tre forme di rappresentanza una è
rispetto al proprio territorio di
origine sono le famose consulte
regionali per le migrazioni
una rispetto al territorio di arrivo e
la source non avete mai sentito dire i
comites sono i comitati per gli italiani
all'estero e sono per ogni
circoscrizione consolare quindi sono
ovunque e il cgie il loro organo di
secondo livello cioè che rappresenta gli
italiani al mondo rispetto al loro luogo
di arrivo
presso il ministero degli affari esteri
la terza forma di rappresentanza e li
farete più sereni perché la conoscete
senz'altro sono i parlamentari eletti
nella circoscrizione estera
questa è la conoscete ma in compenso le
altre due sono più antiche sono nate
negli anni 70 negli anni 80 e a
differenza dei parlamentari hanno una
base associativa e sono tenute da da
volontari allora perché sono importante
queste forme di rappresentanza
per prima cosa perché se tanto tanto che
è sembrata smart l'idea che abbiamo
avuto in 30 a bologna immaginatevi che
questi sono network di associazioni di
italiani
tutto il mondo
per seconda cosa perché sono appena
stati rinnovati i compiti sono stati
eletti ad aprile il cga a settembre tra
l'altro ne faccio parte e la consulta
per esempio quella dell'emilia romagna
sta proprio rinnovandosi in questi
giorni quindi è il momento perfetto per
informarvi per andarli a conoscere per
stimolarli magari per pensare di
candidarvi fa cinque anni
l'ultima ragione per cui sono importanti
e che hanno competenze complementari per
esempio se per caso qualcuno di voi sta
pensando di trasferirsi all'estero
magari che ne so a monaco piuttosto che
a città del messico piuttosto che a
copenhagen adesso sa che può rivolgersi
al comites di quel territorio per farsi
aiutare nell'inserimento per conoscere
un po le dinamiche del luogo di arrivo e
quindi insomma diciamo che svolgono una
funzione di mediatore culturale
se ci sono artisti o imprenditori tra di
voi che sono legati al territorio non
necessariamente regionale ma anche dei
comuni dell'emilia romagna di tutte le
altre regioni magari sarà interessante
per voi andare a contattare la consulta
per preparare dei viaggi o per
sollecitare le comunità all'estero
rispetto alle proprie attività e magari
creare progetti appunto culturali
economici per l'estero
queste sono forme di rappresentanza
importanti ma come dicevamo riguardano
sostanzialmente in acqua essere
cittadini italiani
ora se c'è un dato importante che non
bisogna dimenticare è che vabbè abbiamo
capito che le cifre sono po vaghe però
questo piano che come minimo gli
italiani all'estero sono 4 milioni 600
mila 30 st
636.600 47 di questi 4 milioni e 600
mila ne avete capito più della metà
abitano risiedono dentro l'unione
europea significa che per due milioni e
mezzo di italiani sostanzialmente i
punti di riferimento istituzionali sono
il comune la regione lo stato da cui si
proviene il comune la regione lo stato
in cui si arriva e per tutto l'unione
europea e se vi sembra già un po caotica
la questione sappiate che in realtà
sono 15 milioni i cittadini europei che
vivono in un paese dell'unione diverso
rispetto da quelle di nascita quindi
stiamo allargando sempre di più uno
sguardo e la questione si fa complessa
allora mi permetto di segnalarvi di
nuovo una guida per i diritti e doveri e
soprattutto le forme di partecipazione
rispetto alla cittadinanza europea
qual è la questione che sostanzialmente
quello che abbiamo scoperto con l'adagio
non c'è lotta senza balotta funziona
anche quando ci si trasferisce cioè che
si possono incontrare altre ballotte e
si può cominciare a voler fare altre
lotte per esempio qui mi vedete alle
prese con le reti di associazioni allora
italiane polacche spagnole e portoghesi
a parigi
coordinati da 1 ng francese ci siamo
ritrovati nel 2014 per cercare di fare
capire ai cittadini comunitari che
potevano votare per le elezioni
municipali del loro paese del paese
della città di residenza e anche
scegliere per le elezioni europee votare
per i candidati del proprio paese di
origine o i candidati le proprio paese
di residenza e anche gli è successo
qualcosa di straordinario eravamo tutti
intenti a fare questo progetto e ci
siamo guardati attorno abbiamo pensato
che forse eravamo l'unico coordinamento
di comunità europee su un territorio nel
mondo e quindi ci siamo inventati un
nuovo progetto che ci è stato finanziato
dalla regione il de france che la
regione di parigi e nel prossimo anno
trasformeremo questo coordinamento in
coordinamento permanente perché almeno
appunto chi è sul territorio possa avere
un'idea di che cosa significa forse
almeno per noi essere l'europa dei
popoli
avrete capito che mi piacciono i
cartelloni tra tutti quelli che abbiamo
scritto con questo gruppo di amici sono
poi diventati amici quello forse più
importante è proprio quello con la
domanda di tutte le domande quali europa
vogliamo
è la risposta non la possiamo delegare
ad altri cioè le istituzioni la
burocrazia sono degli strumenti ma siamo
noi gli attori di questa domanda e delle
risposte
e questa risposta la dobbiamo trovare
proprio oggi cioè nella crisi della
grecia con l'arrivo dei migranti che tra
l'altro sono anche loro dei cittadini
mobili e queste sono delle sfide e che
non possiamo più rimandare
un'espressione che forse avete tutti
sentito dire è probabilmente utilizzato
è cittadino del mondo se ci fate caso
questa espressione rinvia a un idea
quella della libertà di poter viaggiare
in giro per il mondo con una valigia e
sentirsi a casa magari con un volo low
cost
ora questo magari ha più a che vedere
con la globalizzazione dei consumi ma
con la cittadinanza un poco meno e il
rischio è che se non sentiamo l'urgenza
di rispondere a queste domande quello
che succede che ci sentiamo cittadini
del mondo e ci risvegliamo cittadini di
nessun luogo oggi spero di avervi
mostrato tante vie diverse per trovare
la vostra strada quella che vi parla di
più per partecipare e spero soprattutto
che sia chiaro che questo almeno per me
è stato sempre l'occasione di
sperimentare tanto divertimento e con
tanti amici